♪ ♪ ♪
- Avec l'arrivée du coronavirus,
la planète entière s'est mise
au ralenti; les rues
se sont vidées. Mais pendant
que l'humain se confinait,
d'autres espèces animales
ont eu le champ libre pour
se réapproprier le territoire.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ces derniers mois, des photos
inusitées d'animaux en ville
ont fait le tour du Web.
Le confinement a donné
aux chercheurs en biologie et en
écologie une occasion inattendue
et unique d'étudier les effets
de l'activité humaine
sur la faune.
♪ ♪ ♪
Des chercheurs de l'Université
St Andrews, au Royaume-Uni,
ont donné un nom à cette pause
forcée de l'activité humaine :
l'anthropause.
♪ ♪ ♪
Grâce à l'anthropause, on a pu
découvrir que l'humain était
le seul facteur qui empêchait
des animaux d'occuper certains
territoires. C'est parce que les
animaux savent instinctivement
quelles zones de leur habitat
sont sécuritaires et
lesquelles sont dangereuses.
Ils ont une image mentale
de leur environnement.
♪ ♪ ♪
Par exemple, les animaux
qui vivent aux abords des routes
savent qu'ils doivent
les éviter. Mais avec
le confinement, les routes sont
moins achalandées et les animaux
considèrent désormais
ces lieux comme sécuritaires.
Pour d'autres espèces,
au contraire, l'effet de
l'anthropause a été dévastateur.
Certains animaux en ville
dépendent beaucoup
de la nourriture laissée
par les humains.
Avec le confinement,
ils se sont retrouvés affamés.
Des projets de recherche
s'intéressent à quantifier
l'effet de l'anthropause sur les
animaux. Le projet international
"COVID-19 Biologging Initiative"
étudiera 279 populations
animales dans différents
habitats de la planète
à l'aide de dispositifs
électroniques miniatures.
Mais un jour, la pandémie
sera finie, l'activité humaine
reprendra comme avant.
Quelles leçons pourra-t-on
tirer de cette anthropause?
♪ ♪ ♪
Selon les chercheurs,
cela nous aura permis
d'identifier les animaux
qui sont particulièrement
vulnérables à l'activité humaine
et d'améliorer la cohabitation
entre notre espèce
et les autre